joining us now house Judiciary Committee
chairman Jim Jordan
first of all Jim let me uh
let me thank you because we I read about
it every day I still like a hard
newspaper I was a paper boy as a kid and
I like to get a hard copy and I still
read through it and of course you know I
got a big pile every day of stuff I read
but you know every day I'm reading about
this you know there was a bank robber
that robbed five banks got out each time
on Nobel robbed another bank he had to
be the worst bank robber in the history
of Bank Robbie but they let him out
every time so I'm glad that you're
allowing the victims to tell their story
that's exactly right Sean album Bragg as
you said said New York's the safest big
city in the country your audience knows
that isn't the case you know you live
there you know that's not the case
far away yeah
and even this facts and figures and
stats about Alvin Bragg's DA's office
revealed that that's not the case so
we're coming up there to talk to the
victims the people who've been impacted
by this crazy left-wing ideology that
says we're not going to put bad guys
people who do harmful things to other
Americans we're not going to put them in
jail and then bad things happen we're
going to talk to those families and
we're not just going to go to New York
we're going to go to other cities I've
talked to our subcommittee crime crime
subcommittee chairman Congressman Biggs
he'll be there with us he wants to go to
other cities and do this same thing but
it is that critical because Alvin Bragg
as you know is going after president
Trump when you have all kinds of things
happening in his town that are harmful
to families who live there let me ask
you your investigation your committee is
looking into whether or not our FBI has
been politicized and our department of
justice has been weaponized you have
many whistleblowers in the FBI coming
forward I've interviewed a couple myself
and I understand that there are many
more coming are you at this early day
based on what you have heard from
whistleblowers that I have not heard and
maybe this audience has not heard are
you convinced the FBI is politicized and
the doj is weaponized
I am son it's a brave whistleblower who
brought us uh came forward and told us
about what was going on in the Richmond
field office they were looking the FBI
in the Richmond field office was looking
to put sources in churches have
informants in Catholic parishes that's
what they were looking to do someone
needs to give him a lesson in the First
Amendment this memorandum that they put
together that we now have a now have
this memorandum talks about doing just
that and it was signed off on by two
senior analysts and the chief division
Council there how can a lawyer sign off
on something like and frankly but for
the Whistleblower I don't know that this
wouldn't still be going on and this
thing was sent out to all the other
field offices now stop and think for a
second yesterday was probably more
Americans in church than any other day
of the year the day we celebrate the
resurrection of our savior more millions
of Americans going to church now what if
this FBI thing would have been carried
out there would be people in the church
spying on fellow parishioners fellow
fellow church goers that that's what
they were looking to do that's how scary
this is what they've done to the first
amendment when you put it in context
remember the FTC a few weeks ago we
learned was asking a private company who
are the journalists you're talking to
name four personally two of those
journalists testified when one of them's
testifying while Democrats are asking
who his sources are the FBI is knocking
on his door and now we learn that here
in the last month now we learn that the
FBI was looking to put informants and
develop sources in churches where you go
to talk to your pastor to your priest
looking to do that that is frightening
stuff and that's why the work we're
doing in this committee I think is so
darn important let me ask you based on
what we have been witnessing and what
you have seen and this this spectacle
that was unfolding last week with
President Trump do you believe that the
clintons and the bidens have been
treated differently than Donald Trump
of course yeah
well of course they have Sean I mean
look I I said they spied on his campaign
they raided his home and now they indict
him and they indict him even though
Alvin Bragg wasn't going to bring the
case but saw that President Trump
announced he's running for president is
leading in all the polls and so they go
after him and I'm actually very very
concerned that they're going to go after
him in Georgia and I'm also concerned
that the special counsel is going to
come forward with an indictment too and
if the special counsel does that think
about this Sean if he does that on the
classified documents issue and they
don't do anything to Joe Biden who's had
classified documents at his home at his
beach house in Chinatown at the Biden
center right he's had him all over the
place if they don't go after uh
President Biden and do something to
president Trump that that is frightening
stuff and I'm afraid that maybe where
things are going I certainly hope that's
not the case but yeah this is the double
certainly hopefully it's not the case in
reality you believe it probably is
because I know I do
I hope not because as as Kim strasso had
in the Wall Street Journal a couple
weeks ago when you crossed this Rubicon
you start having these kind of
indictments done for purely political
reason even Andy McKay even Andy McCabe
said he wasn't too impressed with Alvin
Bragg's rollout of this indictment last
week when you have Andy McCabe saying
things like that you know how political
this whole thing is and going after
president Trump Congressman Jordan great
to have you thank you hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else